[Music]
after 16 years of playing the classical
guitar making recordings touring with
groups playing concerts I've encountered
quite a lot of misconceptions about this
instrument and how it's played so in
today's video I thought it'd be fun to
debunk some common classical guitar
myths quick disclaimer these are of
course my opinions I do believe they're
grounded in historical fact most of them
but if you disagree let me know why in
the comments also if I missed some add
them to the comments myth number one you
have to play with nails today the common
belief is that to play classical guitar
you have to grow the fingernails long on
your plucking hand usually your right
hand to pluck the strings however this
wasn't always the case the pioneering
composers of the 19th century who wrote
the guitar's main repertoire and
developed this technique like sore
karkazi taraga and many others did not
play with nails now of course at the
same time other players did play with
nails they're both historically that
valid but if you talk to most classical
guitarists today they'll say things like
well if you want to be a serious
classical guitarist you have to play
with nails well I don't have nails and
I'm a pretty serious classical guitarist
so not true for more on this subject
check out this video I made
myth number two you need nails to play
tremolo now even among those who've
accepted that playing with or without
nails are both historically valid it's
often believed that to play tremolo uh
you do need Nails tremolo is this really
fascinating technique on the classical
guitar where you rapidly play four
fingers in succession and it makes a
really cool
effect on the guitar
[Music]
now right now I'm playing without nails
sometimes I play with nails sometimes I
play without I do think it's a different
sound with nails it's a bit more of a
bit more percussive a bit more machine
gun like without nails it's a bit more
Brushy but let's remember a very
important historical fact Targa himself
who wrote the most famous tremolo piece
recuerdos de la Alhambra you can check
out my performance of that piece here
Targa didn't play with nails at the end
of his life and he was a big proponent
of playing without nails he thought
there was a magic to it that you
couldn't get with nails so since the man
himself Targa did it and I'm doing it
right now can play tremolo without nails
foreign
ly it is possible
myth number three you need big hands to
play guitar well the classical guitar is
well known for being extremely
technically demanding and one of the
differences of the actual instrument
when compared to like a steel string
acoustic guitar is that the strings are
wider the neck is wider and the strings
are farther apart and the neck is a bit
thicker which makes it very hard to do
things like put your thumb on top of the
neck so when students are learning very
often they come to the conclusion that
you must need very big hands to play the
classical guitar but I think we can
really safely debunk this myth in my
experience I've encountered guitarists
with fingers that are so much shorter
than mine so much longer than mine so
much thinner than mine so much wider
than mine every person has their own
personal anatomy and we're all so quick
to blame our anatomy when things aren't
going right technically on an instrument
before you blame your Anatomy blame
technique it's almost always your
Technique segovia's hands were huge and
and like one of his fingers was like
three of mine so how do they fit it into
these upper frets here I mean that must
have been uh challenging for him the
point is no matter what size and shape
fingers you have I've seen guitarists
Excel so well uh and played better than
me with different size hands than me so
don't blame your Anatomy fix your
Technique and by the way we live in a
good time now where you can buy really
good guitars at different sizes so if
you are on the shorter side and you do
want a smaller guitar get one the
standard classical guitar scale from
here to here is 65 centimeters now they
make a lot of them that are 64
centimeters this guitar this is a Taurus
replica it is 64 centimeters you can get
one that's even shorter than that if you
want you can get a 7 8 guitar if you're
buying for a 11 year old you can get a
three-quarter size guitar or even a half
size guitar so play a guitar that's
right for you and fix your Technique
before you blame your Anatomy
myth number four you need strong fingers
to play the guitar very often in my
lessons with students they'll say things
like oh I don't have enough strength I
need to build more muscle to to play
this well this one applies to all
guitarists one of the worst devices I've
ever seen is this finger grip
strengthener that you can buy online
with springs designed to I don't know
like make little biceps you know on your
on your fingers as if we wanted muscular
fingers you don't want muscular fingers
we don't play the guitar well because
we're muscular beginners don't have weak
muscles and advanced players having
super ripped fingers instead it's all
about technique it's how you use your
fingers learning to use economy of
motion very often at the beginning we're
using the wrong muscles or too many
muscles we're gripping in the wrong way
and therefore we can't get the right
notes down so you're playing your F
major bar chord that all guitarists find
difficult when they first come to the
guitar and they it sounds like this
[Music]
I can't get the notes to sound it's not
because you're too weak you're not
allocating pressure in the right way if
you use gravity the weight of the world
and you hang your arm from the guitar
the bar takes care of itself you're
actually using less muscles so please
don't buy these silly finger
strengthening things they probably
actually hurt you more than they help
you by the way if you need help with
your bar chords recently one of our
teachers at my online music school did a
full workshop on the subject so check
out this video here it's in the link in
the description if you want to improve
your bar chords
myth number five you need to tune to a
equals 440 Hertz today pitch has become
standardized uh so when we say play me
this a it usually means an a at 440
Hertz I think it's that a uh and
orchestras tuned to it most of the time
and if you go to electronic keyboard or
a guitar tuner everything is calibrated
around that idea but it's important to
know that for most of History pitch was
relative so what you called an a could
vary quite a lot depending on where and
when you were this a could have sounded
like this or this or this or this or
this there's quite a bit of a spectrum
here within at least a major third that
all could have been called a depending
on where and when you were so you might
say so what now we have a good
calculated a let's just use that well
the reason I say this is because I would
encourage people to experiment with the
pitch of their instruments with their
guitars in general for example
experiment with lowering the pitch I
find that with specific strings and
specific guitars if you lower the tuning
to say 415 Hertz or everything tuned
down a half step not only is it nice
because you have a lot less tension on
the strings the guitar has a warmer
sound and you might find something in
between there where the guitar actually
sounds wonderful maybe your guitar
sounds best at 419 Hertz I don't know
have you tried if you only ever tune
your guitar to 440 Hertz you might be
missing something so I would recommend
experimenting with the pitch today's
video is brought to you by classical
guitar Pro that's my brand new online
classical guitar course which is six
hours 53 videos it's a whole curriculum
designed to teach you what you would
normally learn in the first six months
to a year of classical guitar lessons so
if you want to learn classical guitar
but are stuck struggling reading music
or struggling to learn the techniques
check out classicalguitara dashpro.com
to learn more
myth number six louder guitars are
better in my many conversations with
luthiers and guitarists one thing seems
clear the best guitars are very loud
guitars and the general trend of Guitar
Building today is to make guitars which
are as loud as possible and it makes
sense why they're doing this players are
playing in bigger and bigger Halls
sometimes giant Orchestra Halls that are
meant for 60 person orchestras and
rather than amplify they want a super
loud and resonant instrument so the
guitars end up being very overbuilt
heavy people end up using super super
high attention strings and the guitars
are even made for it so these things are
just cannons you know the reason I'm
calling this one a myth I'm saying that
the idea that louder guitars are better
is a myth is because historically
guitars are not this Canon they're not
this percussive thing that plays at you
it's a seductive Charming romantic
instrument that pulls you into its world
I think we lose so much of the charm of
the instrument when we try to make it
louder louder and louder with higher and
higher tension strings I've played so
many modern guitars today where the
strings are so high tension and the
instruments are made for it so that's
slurs
become impossible vibrato
doesn't even work on the instrument and
this means that all those beautiful
elegant light slurred passages in
classical guitar music become heavy
[Music]
duty of passages like that are how easy
it sounds how graceful it is the other
important historical fact here is that
guitars were never designed to play in
giant Orchestra halls with 3 000 person
audiences the guitar is an instrument
made for and perfectly suited to play in
Salon Style music this means small
recitals for maybe a room full of 20
people and if everyone started talking
you wouldn't be able to hear it and in
my experience when I perform concerts
often I push the audience I play softer
and softer how softly can I actually
take the music down and what I've
noticed is people kind of lean in and
you can hear a pin drop those are the
most beautiful moments for me
myth number seven the more you practice
the better you'll get of course this tip
applies to all musicians but classical
guitarists have a lot of demanding music
to learn a lot of challenging techniques
and so we have to practice a lot be
forewarned more practice isn't good good
quality practice is good but you can
certainly practice in a way for hours
and hours and hours that makes you worse
why is that the reason is because muscle
memory is a double-edged sword you need
it to play very complicated things
fast passages like that one require a
lot of repetition of the same movement
but if you practice the wrong things
repeatedly which so many of us do your
hands will memorize those mistakes
forever your fingers don't know the
difference between the things you wanted
and the things you don't it just knows
repetition so practice slowly accurately
and efficiently show your hands only the
things you want them to repeat and then
do that a lot so no more practice
doesn't make you a better player if
you're not careful it can make you worse
what you really want is quality practice
and the last thing I'll say about this
one is actually there is a point
especially as we get older where the
more you practice you have to be careful
because tension in your body can lead to
fatigue and inflammation can lead to
Chronic injuries quality is always
better than quantity so thank you guys
for watching again I want to say that
the topics covered in this video are my
own opinions and I am very open-minded
if you disagree with me let me know why
I'm very I'd be very curious to know
where I might be going wrong these are
all just my feelings based on what I've
read researched and played so let's get
a conversation going in the comment
section what other myths are there about
the classical guitar that might need
debunking if any so please do subscribe
if you haven't already it really helps
the channel you can also check out my
patreon page directly support the
creation of more videos like this in the
future and I hope to see you all next
time
foreign
[Music]